ドロンビアって感じだな
スピーカーとかバールもおせんとか
お酒も
歩くバールみたいな感じ?
それは楽しそう
すごい
そういうロバが何頭かいるってことです
お酒を組んでいるロバと
スピーカーのロバと
お酒を飲みながら
夜も
お酒を飲む
すごい一日楽しそう
すごいよ
夜になる
お酒を飲んで
よっからって落ちちゃう人とか
とてもいい
馬
馬よくてもよっからってたら
でも
よく
この馬はきっと守る
馬が山道を知ってるからね
自分の家までは帰りません
なんかちょっと
スピーカー昇和されたロバも
お前そうな絵
絵面
絵が
背中の両髪を両方にスピーカーも
人間はお酒を飲んで
浮かれて
こんな感じ
ロバのコンペティションが
マラトンみたい
人
ロバを引っ張って
走る
東京マラトンみたい
でもロバ
へー
人が
速く走らないと勝てない
そうそうそう
ロバを引っ張る
ロバが引っ張るんじゃないですよ
人間が引っ張るんですよ
両方ともね
初めに人間だけ
ロバが
協力をしないと
意味がない
それもちょっと
レイクみたいなの?
もしかしたら
言うことを聞かないかもしれないし
うまくこう
ちゃんと意思の
交通ができて
勝ちみたいな
そんな感じなのか
でもとっても
流行っているアメリカ
でもなんか
名古屋な
アメリカで
コロンビアじゃなくて
アメリカ
日本ってあんまり
ロバいないですもんね
あんまり見ないかも
そうだね
普通見るってことですね
ロバがね
そう
コロンビアやたって
普通ある
あ、そう
ロバは
ロバ祭りがあります
えぇ
ロバ祭りがある
ロバ祭り?
えぇ
かわいい
よりかわいい
ロバ祭りすごい
かわいい感じがする
そう
立派なロバがいる
確かに
よく絵になってる
ロバの絵を
うん
ロバって
人間乗せるより
なんかこう
荷物は